>> Greg: WHILE THE EMINENT
DOMAIN SPENT NEW WAYS HOW
BIDEN WILL EVISCERATE TRUMP.
THE FIRST HOST OF THE DEBATE
WILL INCLUDE RACHEL MADDOW.
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE IT COULD
HAVE BEEN JOHN BRENNAN AND
JOY BEHAR.
TALKING ABOUT TAKING THE
MODERATE OUT OF THE
MODERATOR.
RACHEL IS THE LEFT OF MARX
AND I DON'T MEAN THE
BROTHERS OR RICHARD.
SHE IS TOTALLY CAPABLE BUT
ALSO TOTALLY BIASED.
HER LIVELIHOOD DEPENDS ON
IT.
AND AFTER SHE SPENT TWO
YEARS HOCKING A FANTASY THAT
PAINTED PRESIDENT AS A
RUSSIAN STOOGE.
DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD LET
HER NEAR THE STAGE?
>> THIS GUY KEEPS TURNING UP
DOES STAN TEEN CLAIM NIC HE
IS STILL RUSSIAN MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE.
CLEM NIC.
A SHORT MAN WHO GOES BY --
THIS GUY COS STAN TEEN.
ALUMINUM SMELTERS, SLEEPING
SMELTERS.
SABOTAGE IN HIS SMELTERS
CAME TO HIS SMELTERS.
ALEX VANDER.
ALEX VANDER SWAN.
ATON MIC NUMBER 24.
CHROMIUM PLANT IN
KAZAKHSTAN.
NEXT TIME YOU SEE SOMETHING
CHROME PLATED TAKE A DEEP
BREATH, COUGH IT OUT AND
THINK OF THE TRUMP SOHO BIG
STORY, TICK, TICK, TICK,
BOOM.
STARTED TICKING AGAIN, TICK,
TICK, TICK, TICK.
FOUR HOURS LATER.
BOOM, BOOM.
YOU ARE STRESSING ME OUT.
HE STARTS TICK, TICK,
TICKING AGAIN.
>> WHAT IF FOX NEWS HAD
PULLED THIS STUNT AND PICKED
A HIGHLY MODERATE SADLY
DIAMOND AND SILK WERE BUSY.
WE ASSUMED OUR MEDIA PALS
WOULD GET WIND OF IT.
GOD HOW LITTLE A RIPPLE THIS
MADE IN THE MEDIA POND.
INSTEAD THEY JUST PUSH
ABSURD HALLUCINATIONS.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE IS
TALKING ABOUT NOW IF HE
LOSES, TRUMP, HE WON'T GO.
I ABSOLUTELY THINK HE WILL
NOT LEAVE.
>> Greg: HOW DERANGED DO YOU
HAVE TO BE NOT JUST TO
BELIEVE THAT BUT TO ACTUALLY
SAY IT OUT LOUD.
THE DERANGEMENT BLINDS YOU
SO MUCH YOU FORGET IT'S YOUR
SIDE TRYING TO UNDO AN
ELECTION.
IT'S NOT TRUMP RESISTING THE
VOTE OF THE VOTERS BUT THE
LEFT CONCOCTING WAYS TO
SEIZE POWER THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE ELECTIONS.
I GET IT IT'S BEEN A ROUGH
TWO YEARS FOR THE MEDIA.
>> THE COUNTRY IS DOING
GREAT AND THAT'S BAD IF YOUR
INDUSTRY IS BUILT ON BAD
NEWS.
THE ONLY THING THEY HAVE
GOING FOR THEM AN ACTIVE
IMAGINATION.
TOO BAD THE PUBLIC HAS
LEARNED TO IGNORE IT.
ALL RIGHT KATIE, THEY KNEW
THEY COULD MAKE THIS BRAZEN
CHOICE BECAUSE THEY KNEW NO
ONE WOULD CALL HIM ON IT,
RIGHT?
>> Katie: YEAH.
THE IDEA THEY WILL PICK
RACHEL MADDOW BUT WON'T DO A
FOX NEWS DEBATE WITH
MODERATORS IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS REALLY IS
ASTOUNDING TO ME.
RACHEL MADDOW IS BASICALLY A
CONSPIRACY THEORIST LOOK
BACK AT ALL THE RUSSIA
COVERAGE SHE DID.
CLAIMED FACTUAL.
WHAT SHE ACTUALLY GOT RIGHT,
VERY, VERY LITTLE OF IT.
SHE SAT THERE WHEN LAWRENCE
O'DONNELL WHO IS ON AFTER
HER SAID THAT MAYBE
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDED TO
SYRIA AND THAT THE SYRIANS
LAUNCHED A CHEMICAL WEAPONS
ATTACK TO DISTRACT AWAY FROM
THE RUSSIA ISSUE.
I MEAN, THAT'S A PRETTY
SERIOUS CON SPUR TOLER
CHARGE TO MAKE.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE DOUBLE
STANDARD, RIGHT?
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA,
CONSERVATIVES ARE NEVER
ALLOWED TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS.
WHENEVER THEY GET A QUESTION
AT THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
BRIEFING OR DURING A PRESS
CONFERENCE THEY ARE BERATED
BY THE PRESS AS NOT REAL
JOURNALISTS CAPABLE OF
ASKING QUESTIONS.
RACHEL MADDOW CAN MODERATE A
DEBATE.
IT'S A DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> Greg: JUAN, AT FOX WE
HAVE OUR COMMENTATORS BUT WE
LABEL EVERYTHING.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE FOX NEWS
FRIDGE, YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE GETTING, DO YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN?
YOU HAVE YOUR STRAIGHT VODKA
AND THEN HAVE YOU YOUR VODKA
AND SODA.
>> Katie: WHAT ARE YOU,
GREG?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
AM I'M COME AQUATIC
AM I'M JOME AQUATIC
AM I'M JUIE AQUATIC
AM I'M JUICEAQUATIC
AM I'M JUICE.QUATIC
>> Katie: YOU HAVE TO
SQUEEZE A LOT.
>> Juan: KIND OF TART.
I WOULD SAY GENERALLY WE
HAVE HAD PEOPLE WHO HAVE
OPINIONS AT THE DEBATE
MODERATORS.
I THINK THIS IS SORE OF
EGREGIOUS.
I THINK WE TRY TO ABIDE HERE
AT FOX THAT THERE IS A LINE
BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
OPINION AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
NEWS.
SOME PEOPLE CRITICIZE.
LOOK, I HAVE SEEN THIS LINE,
AND I THINK THE PUBLIC IS
BEST SERVED WHEN IT'S NOT
BLURRED.
I HAVE SEEN IT HERE.
I HAVE SEEN IT AT "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
AT "THE WASHINGTON POST" I
WAS BOTH REPORTER AND
EDITORIAL WRITER.
WHEN I WAS A REPORTER THE
EDITORIAL PEOPLE DIDN'T TELL
ME WHAT TO DO.
WHEN I WAS EDITORIAL WRITER
I NEVER TALKED TO THE
JOURNALISTS.
IT SEEMS TO ME AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS DONE A DEBATE FOR
FOX, IT WOULD -- I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT MSNBC IS DOING
THIS AND I THINK TO PICK UP
ON WHAT YOU WERE SAYING I'M
SURPRISED THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ISN'T
SAYING HEY, WE DON'T LIKE IT
BECAUSE IT OPENS THE DOOR TO
CONSERVATIVES DOING THE SAME
THING DOWN THE LINE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
THAT OPENS THE DOOR FOR
JESSE WATTERS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT
HANNITY SAID BY THE WAY.
>> Jesse: DIAMOND AND SILK
AND WATERS.
THERE YOU GO.
PROBABLY IN CONTRACT THOUGH
TO MODERATE THE DEBATES AND
NBC DIDN'T WANT TO CAUSE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH BIGGEST
POLITICAL STAR.
GETTING SUED FOR A QUARTER
OF A BILLION DOLLARS BY THE
COVINGTON BLAZE.
THEY SPIKED THAT EXPOSE.
THINGS DIDN'T WORK OUT WITH
MEGYN KELLY AND BRIAN
WILLIAMS AND MATT LAUER
THERE IS A LOFT PROBLEMS
OVER THERE THEY WILL
OVER THERE THEY HILL
OVER THERE THEY HAVL
OVER THERE THEY HAVE A LOT
OF PROBLEMS OVER THERE HER
BRAND HAS SUFFERED BECAUSE
SHE LIED FOR TWO YEARS.
THEY NEED TO REALIGN HER
BRAND WITH THE NBC NEWS
DIVISION TO RESUSCITATE HER
CREDIBILITY NOW BECAUSE EVEN
THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTERS AREN'T ALLOWED ON
HER SHOW BECAUSE SHE IS TOO
FRINGE.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
ALL OF THIS, KENNEDY?
>> Kennedy: I LOOK AT ALL OF
THIS IF I'M AN INDEPENDENT
OR DEMOCRATIC VOTER AND I'M
LOOKING AT THIS FIELD I WANT
TO HEAR FROM THEM.
I WANT TO HEAR HOW THEY TAKE
EACH OTHER ON AND HOW THEY
PRESENT THEIR IDEAS AND IF
THEY CAN DO SOMETHING OTHER
THAN ATTACK THE PRESIDENT,
WHICH RACHEL MADDOW CAN'T DO
THAT THE BIGGEST WORRY FOR
VOTERS LIKE THAT IS SHE IS
GOING CONTINUE TO SETTER
HERSELF TOO MUCH INTO THESE
DEBATES WHEN REALLY BOTH OF
THEM ARE GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY CROWDED AND YOU
HAVE TO BE VERY PRECISE IN
HOW YOU EXTRACT INFORMATION
AND THE QUELLS YOU ASK.
THE CANDIDATES HAVE TO
THINK.
AND LORD KNOWS THAT I DON'T
KNOW THAT SHE IS CAPABLE OF
ASKING A REALLY TOUGH
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION.
AND YOU SAW WITH SHARLA MAIN
AND ELIZABETH WARREN IT
TAKES ONE FOLLOW-UP QUESTION
TO COMPLETELY TRIP UP A
CANDIDATE.
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU
HAVE SUCH A CROWDED FIELD.
>> Greg: SHE IS NOT GOING TO
ASK QUESTIONS THAT THE-THAT
WILL PULL ANYBODY TO THE
MIDDLE.
IT WILL JUST BE HOW LIBERAL
CAN YOU GET OR HOW LEFT
WING.
>> Kennedy: WHICH CANDIDATES
DOES SHE LIKE BEST?
IS SHE GOING TO GO EASIER ON
THEM?
AND THAT'S ALSO GOING TO BE
A DISSERVICE.
>> Katie: I DON'T MIND HER
ASKING THE QUESTIONS.
I MIND THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD ABOUT WHO GETS TO
ASK THE QUESTION.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE CAPABLE
OF REPORTING AND ALSO HAVING
OPINIONS.
THIS IDEA THAT ONLY THE LEFT
IS ALOUD AND FAR LEFT IS
ALLOWED TO ASK THE QUESTIONS
LEGITIMATELY, THAT'S WHERE
IT GETS RIDICULOUS.
LIKE IF RACHEL MADDOW IS
CAPABLE OF ASKING QUESTIONS
SO IS JESSE WATTERS.
>> Jesse: IS SHE GOING TO
ASK LIZ WARREN ABOUT FAKE
INDIAN HERITAGE.
SHE HAS HAD HER ON HER SHOW
THREE TIMES MORE THAN ANY
OTHER DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE SHE
HAS BEEN ON RACHEL MOD DO
YOU A LOT.
IT'S CLEAR THERE IS A
ROOTING INTEREST THERE.
>> Greg: OUTRAGE.
BILL MAHER IS A SMART GUY.
HOW CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT A
PRESIDENT WOULD SAY I'M NOT
LEAVING?
THAT IS LIKE THE MOST
INSIDIOUS THING.
>> Juan: DID TRUMP SAY HE IS
NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO
ABIDE BY THE RESULTS?
>> Jesse: IT WAS HILLARY
THAT DIDN'T ABIDE BY THE
RESULTS.
SHE STILL THINKS SHE WON,
JESSE.
>> Kennedy: THIS IS WHY BILL
BARR HAS LOST IT.
HE USED TO BE FUNNY AND
RELEVANT.
IS HE ACTING AS THOUGH THE
PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY BEEN
DEFEATED.
WE HAVEN'T HAD THE ELECTION
YET.
WE HAVE A LOT OF RUN-UP
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN SO STOP
ACTING LIKE HE HAS
BARRICADED HIMSELF INSIDE